salute and smiles as he left trump tower
if donald trump is feeling the pressure
he wasn't showing it
how do you feel mr trump how do you feel
he was coming here the new york offices
of the u.s attorney general to answer
questions under oath
about his past as a businessman and
property tycoon
allegations he falsely misrepresented
the value of assets
but ahead of six hours of testimony the
former president said he'd take the
fifth amendment his constitutional right
to silence
i declined to answer the questions he
said in a statement under the rights and
privileges afforded to every citizen
under the united states constitution
this from a man who has four years said
the fifth amendment was for losers
taking the fifth
i think it's disgraceful i want the
fifth amendment i want immunity
the reason they get immunity is because
they did something wrong if you're
innocent why are you taking the fifth
amendment
fifth amendment fifth amendment fifth
amendment
horrible
trump's decision to remain silent though
doesn't come without legal risk that the
questions are about whether he committed
financial fraud whether he inflated his
assets and deflated improperly his
liabilities in order to get loans or
appear more profitable you can
ask a jury to draw the adverse inference
that that is indeed what happened
the investigation in new york is just
one of several ensnaring donald trump
it's been quite a week for the former
president who's lost a long-running
battle to keep his tax records private
and face fresh allegations he broke the
law by destroying presidential records
including flushing some of them down
toilets
a week that started with donald trump
becoming the first american ex-president
to have a home searched by the fbi
he become the first former president to
be charged with a criminal offense if
any of these investigations lead to an
indictment no sign of that yet but
prosecutors are piling on the pressure